both teams blowing our minds with some
truly truly beautiful counter-strike oh
is it happening again Henry what is this
I just don't know what to say anymore
why are all these coming from this just
sick
guys csgo is a game all about precision
from individual players skill to the
management of team economies to the
timing of plays but sometimes you got to
go off script and off meta and do
something truly special that's why this
week on best-of we're taking a look at
the most insane meta defying strats and
csgo that actually worked and a few that
didn't for starters we're gonna look at
some mind-blowing 200 IQ plays for the
minds of CS goes best this is so meta
right it's triple it's a true boost to
shoot some all plus some boost plays
that blew our mind the first time we saw
them he sees them now they're straight
headshot they have no idea Smith's
looking confused and dazed and a handful
of peanut brain strats that just didn't
work out trying to miss the sound of
dropping again they dropped after he
stopped shooting
now speaking of peanut brain play guys
if you still haven't picked up one of
your score esports t-shirts well that's
a 0 IQ play right there what I do is to
say yeah now rectify that go on over to
the score esports new online merged
apartment a link to that will be pinned
in a comment section below there's one
more thing guys before you go flaming us
in the comments section but this video
we are not including spur-of-the-moment
plays like simples falling off
we're talking about premeditated tactics
here things that are called before the
round even starts sake of Islamic tatami
deep alleys autonomy take your device
and five six plenty until either other
defuse kit up on def J I'm gonna be on
his opener oh there we go the body wall
bang be able to give that a seat there
we go Cooper out of the game we did we
do have a real eco it's it's so rare and
you can see oh my god that much Stan and
the money the money factor is important
and look at the guns
aw peacefully they're ready to shoot
some ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and
not in this lifetime he is destroyed
attention to victory and look at what
apex sees here now we've got five eight
W keys picked up against the five ak's
of Navi fnatic are certainly having a
grand old time
they've got eleven rounds on city side
car well the second film applies to all
of the teams that have been treating
already and watching they all know what
this feels like but how do you get out
from under
JW want the other side to pick it up
though me W he's shot to take him down
and now it's on ceased one on three he
hasn't got the bomb he hasn't got the
time he's simply out of luck now but
that's a lot of things star as well is
that individual prowess they always
believe that they can come back from any
score line Oh Guardian Slovakian
superstar ally has the AWP if they lose
this round that's gonna be preventative
double eco going forward so this is
everything for them yeah double equals
roomful we were in the dead middle of
the half this could go something like 12
- VP I was get right seems but this
could be potentially a double e cutting
board that brush
it wasn't just us trolling or being
disrespectful to a team that we on paper
should be there's actually a little bit
more thought that went into it everybody
by Zeus and just play close angles well
guys after watching that last section I
feel smarter already
now let's keep this video going with
some boost plays that blew our minds the
first time we saw them but he couldn't
get it this time why not do it with some
support though have another player there
and you know if you hadn't our players
that could probably get the trade oh
good boy not timing on the aggression
our pancake not gonna peak boost instead
that's a clever way oh my goodness that
is a very clever way well done renegades
well done nifty coccyx had no idea and
nifty and the site is gonna close it
down in a goddamn sexy style all of -
they're still waiting the patience game
coming against puck them coming out of
squeak Doris while he's here he sees
them down there straight head shot they
have no idea Smith's looking confused
and dazed and there's gonna be a
follower
becoming ketamine six the humerus whoa
are they jumping around trying to check
no I think used to show me there it is
is rainy down death from upon one would
esteem others feel so much time you come
Oh was this this is wiping news it is
just keep giving Guardians take it down
therefore neck cities all I was gonna
say not done yet butthole just ducks
under he's down to twenty-five and they
were just trying to piece that together
cause he could not save me think it all
hang on he's finished the job II start
it takes down cold and where is this
innovation coming both teams
both of them blowing our minds with some
truly truly beautiful counter-strike
what is this I just don't know what to
say anymore why are all these coming
from this is sick this has been saving
this for the big land opportunities and
they're delivering three months back I
think those where it gets you it takes
four people on the students spot into
into the end okay let's see antique all
this is sick antique antique is on top
oh that that's dirty so there's a couple
of players going to anonymous hobby
parts a Claudia could all be in trouble
and you do not expect that antique oh
what a beast of an angle they found to
give a name okay they're all towards be
sorry it's very thing he's gonna come
behind them and Roy doesn't go fast now
they'll get flanked are you serious holy
smokes
what down I told you I never wanna let
straight get me other way another job
well we have it we've got to have a
skyscraper
that is unbelievable this is so over I
know I love a good boost guys impressive
smart calculated now if that intimidated
you a little bit well I got good news
our next section is full of failed
strats that are gonna make you feel like
a genius
pretty good stuff I I definitely like it
trying to miss the sound of dropping
again they dropped after he stopped
shooting shrouding skadoodle enshroud
again with the mp7 as they do just shut
down that whole flank yeah that's one
two a third one picked up is it gonna be
more more negative yeah come on alright
so prepare your headsets ladies and
gentleme B turn up the volume a little
bit so you can feel the full quality of
what you're about to experience because
this is going to keep completely crazy
exist is waiting in the middle here
maybe they're gearing up for the
negative Championships smoke smoke he's
just pret and thumbs down and does the
opening assist with another one will
still drop a kill asked were waiting and
gets the shot on get right it's on
forest and Fryeburg they're spray
through the smoke here he comes Russian
crude and crystal with the jumping
headshot on forest private US alone he's
sneaking around with it with a Negev
it's not really a sneaky weapon but he's
trying to make him party goes down busy
here now pistol is everything and it's
the Julie's alright fnatic let's see
what you got
all the Julie's they are having a great
time
it's gonna be structure gonna push on
strokes he managed to pick off Thompson
gets one gonna get the second it's still
crawling by the way that
how can you take this seriously finally
they're not crawling anymore Crystal's
gonna pick what I'll pick the second one
off and pencil will pick up around here
it comes the second half an IEP winning
this fish around with winning the game
and look at that four five dual Berettas
they have no respect for today and this
is devil watch Crouch play I love this
they're trying to guess her here crystal
he's reloading has the wrong time
crystal when this smoke disappears all
hell's gonna break loose and he's even
shooting at my face range docking right
now it's actually working out for an IP
oh my god I foreign aid Oh with the duel
police say they couldn't try and shoot
them back he gets the they can see them
now crawling around the crystal is gonna
pick up another guy that's gonna be a
triple oh man it's crouching crab duel
elites Oh guys that's all we got for you
on best of this week I hope you took
away a few strats you can use in your
comp games and there's probably a few
you want to avoid Oh guys if you want
more content just like this you know
what to do
boost up in the comment section wallbang
the subscribe button and one tap that
like i'll see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]